so let's bring in uh Petra poroshenko
then yet again another bombardment in
Kiev the city where you are suffering a
deeply former president
first of all we have a very difficult 20
days the most difficult because
of the world only these like 12 missiles
grew his missiles was attacking severely
an object in here where are we now
it's happening just a few hundred meters
from here and definitely this is the
changes of the Russian Russian tactics
because if before you want to keep the
cities untouched and make a attempt to
move further in Ukrainian territory when
Ukrainian Armed Forces which we together
created in a starting from the year 2014
and I am proud that for the last eight
years including my presidency we create
one of the strongest and most efficient
army in the world we we stop the Russian
army and the Russia pay a huge price by
13
000 Russian soldiers which were stay
here forever and with the big numbers of
the wounded and prisoners of war and
with this situation I think that we
should continue this effective action
from Ukrainian Army and for these things
we need to additional
additional steps Point number one this
is the
second round we are not waiting for the
NATO troops NATO soldiers but we
definitely need
everything from nutrition to ammunition
from anti-aircraft to anti-tank and the
Ukrainian Army should have something to
fight with the Russian soldiers and it
seems to me Churchill said the before
the World War II if you give me the
tools we do your job this is exactly the
same time and that would be easy
understandable mentioning your great
prime minister and the point number two
this is the situation for the land list
from the old NATO member states we are
ready to pay for that we are ready to
release them but please deliver for us
not only empty tank and anti-aircraft
but jet fighters especially the old
Soviet jet filters MiG-29 which you
don't need and with that situation we
return the control we don't need your
pilot but we return the control on the
airspace and that would be the cover for
the nuclear power station that would be
the cover for civilian object and that
would be the cover for the Ukrainian
troops which protecting Europe because
you should understand
we fight not only for our soil we fight
for the
Democracy for the freedom and for the
west and Putin is make an aggression not
against Ukraine he make an aggression in
every single nation of the NATO of
Europe and the history of the Free World
is being forged here in Ukraine right
now and with this situation definitely
Mr poroshenko but we we were at a
funeral today for very senior officers
Ukrainian officers who were killed in
the attack because you know on the air
base in yavareev on Sunday for very
senior officer how many more people are
you willing to sacrifice how many more
Ukrainian soldiers militia volunteers
you know it will you keep fighting
Point number one exactly on this
yavourif uh Center for security and
peacekeeping I was with the leaders of
United States Great Britain and this is
the uh
just through in my heart but this is the
question for you
is it do you understand that Ukraine do
not give up and Ukraine will fight uh
Forever Until the victory but please we
need that that would be
our own job and my question how many
died Justin yavariv this is 37 people
were killed by the Russian missiles
attack and this is happening in less
than 20 miles from the NATO border and
it was a symbolic attack because exactly
on this Center for peacekeeping and
security which was established for the
very efficient symbol for the
cooperation between Ukraine and NATO
which was open with my presence now the
it was under missiles attack of Russia
and this is the symbol that Putin never
stop on Ukraine Putin go further and
this type of funeral of Ukraine man hero
Ukrainian hero who sacrificed their
lives for
this for the freedom and for the
democracy and more your support
less victim
very simple arithmetic
and delay with your support means more
victim more blood more lives of
Ukrainian civilians and more lives of
Ukrainian soldiers and you and we
understand what does it mean you will
understand how we surprise the World by
our unit
from the 24th of February we have now
completely different universe
and we also surprised
on day 20 when
yeah Mr President we're nearly three
weeks in or your country is nearly three
weeks into this war just briefly if you
can do you have a better idea now than
you did at the start what President
Putin wants out of this
oh
please
don't trust Putin
please don't be afraid
[Music]
because Putin go as far as we together
allow them to go
and if it will be strong and united we
stop putting
if you find out you compromise this
Putin Putin go further
today he has a compromise
for demanding Ukrainian Crimea Ukrainian
dombas tomorrow he will demand from the
Great Britain Scotland day after
tomorrow he will demand on the from the
United States Alaska Putin wants to
destroy not only Ukraine but the core
West including UK and U.S and the
earlier will stop him
the more uh on the Eastern flank of the
Europe that would be much cheaper price
which world will pay for the peace and
security don't try to to make a
compromise with Putin because that would
be Munich in the year 1938.
that time hit the uh with the
Chamberlain
thing that they deliver the peace
this is not working